qui a énormément de poésie je trouve
dans ton film je touche je trouve que le
livre était plus plus plus dur que tu
n'as rang d'une film plus parfois plus
léger cette poésie tutelle était
évidente pour toi honnêtement on pense
pas ça quand on travaille la seule chose
que je peux dire c'est que le personnage
du livre qui m'intéressait plus cet
égard perry cours d'arrêt court alias
navel perez biscayart des grands acteurs
découvert à cette occasion et d'abricots
est un artiste frustré est un artiste
martyrisé est un artiste à la
sensibilité exacerbée et qui s'exprime
elle également qui est des dessins via
des masses etc
c'est celui là je le met en exergue
parce que c'est celui c'était mon idéal
finalement quelqu'un qui fait aucune
compromission
je voulais sublimer ce personnage qui
fait des masques avec très peu de
matériaux mais les matchs simplement
sublime en réalité c'est cécile
kretschmann scuteri des masques avec un
bossé pendant presque un an
c'est super mal a fait un boulot
remarquable voilà donc c'est ça qui fait
que d'un coup le film gagne en
esthétisme gagnant en plaisir de cinéma
tout simplement et didier galy ce qu'il
est dingue albert frappe la tête quand
tu es sur un tournage à ce plaisir je
disais du cadre de l'image et est à la
fois de la direction d'acteurs comme
comment tu tu gères les deux on va t'on
prépare beaucoup sur ce film n est idiot
la préparation ici même de préparation
dont des répétitions il est évident
qu'il avait le talent de ce qu'il soit
il fallait vraiment qu'ils travaillent
par rapport à cette voie par avancis rue
des masques par rapport à ses yeux donc
des climats ce qui arriva il fallait
qu'ils travaillent qu'ils s'approprient
ces personnages là qui à chaque fois tu
es différent j'aime beaucoup quand il
fait d'elle la femme aux cheveux bleus
c'est un de ces masques préférées il
épouse une démarche une grasse
extrêmement féminine quand il fait
professeur tâcherons c'est un vieux
monsieur qui marchent elles t'ont ils
s'amusaient ya travers lui bien sûr
edouard ferry construit
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
je me suis entraîné un peu en danse
dessin piano c'était des choses pour
être un peu nourri de l'univers
artistique puisque c'est interdit ce mec
là est parce qu il peut quasiment pas
parlé et en tout cas beaucoup moins que
les autres personnages
c'était le travail n'était plus là
dessus être déjà empêché de d'avoir un
visage
avoir une voix détruites face à ces
limitations qui peut aussi être assez
libérale tri plus oui mais du coup ça
demande un peu de travail parce que nous
on est un peu les comédiens des fois on
est un peu trop gâtée par le regard par
les mots et du coup les mentions moi je
crois qu'elles passent pas toujours à
travers les la parole quoi
[Applaudissements]
là aussi les répétitions ton beaucoup
aidé à trouver le personnage ou tu la
trouves est quasiment les premiers jours
du tournage non non ça va ça m'a aidé au
début j avais un petit peu à reculons à
répétition parce que j'avais cette
espèce de réflexe un peu bête de me dire
qu'on allait altérer le naturel le
spontané naturel est très relatif en
plus naturel de maintenant on n'est pas
forcément le même que qu'en 1920 et même
si c'est une langue moderne ce n'est pas
une langue contemporaine donc est les
particules est exactement comme on parle
maintenant
donc il y avait un travail à faire aussi
sur la langue et sur la manière
d'articuler ce texte et il fallait qu'on
arrive qu'on arrive prêt à jouer en
faire une toute dernière et moi j'étais
comme comme un poisson 20 mois parce que
je trouve qu'il ya pas mieux que le
travail pour quand on a le trac quand on
doute et c'est pour pour apaiser ces
craintes et pour aller au devant des
choses qui sont à faire mais il faut
bosser et il est dans cette énergie là
c'est vraiment fédérateur